do you know his name that's the focus
of tonight's angle
that question was posed by activists and
protesters for weeks after the killing
of george floyd
it was meant to jar the nation into
focusing on police brutality
and it worked floyd's name and visage
became synonymous with the suffering
that comes from racial injustice of
course there were others who simply used
his name for their own twisted political
agendas
as if burning down our cities would
bring mr floyd back or
solve underlying problems of course it
just
merely made matters worse and in the
intervening weeks
since the upheaval in late may many more
african-american families have lost
loved ones to violence
at least 144 have been murdered since
june
1st in chicago alone including these
children
three-year-old meckie james one-year-old
sincere gaston
seven-year-old natalia wallace all
shot dead but unlike with george floyd
the general public
won't remember them because the
activists
don't find their stories useful
and the media also pushing a political
agenda
they basically just yawn last week in
milwaukee
a well-known passionate figure in the
community someone who had supported
every issue from police reform and other
liberal causes
but lately he had been holding homemade
pro-trump signs that man
was murdered he also happened to be
african-american
he was shot and killed outside his
office just after noon
while he was sitting in a lawn chair
this happened in broad daylight
do you know his name i bet you don't
it's bernell trammell saw the cops pull
up
the vans ambulance firefighters
and we sat and watched they gave cpr for
about 15 to 20 minutes
security cameras captured these images
of the suspect and police are continuing
to investigate
but the milwaukee sentinel journal
reported just a few days ago that
reggie moore director of milwaukee's
office of violence prevention
said he recently intervened in a dispute
between trammell
and a young man moore thought the
incident was related to a
trump sign that trammell was carrying
and wisconsin senator ron johnson a
republican tweeted this
on the news of mr trammel's tragic death
bernal trammell was known to many in
milwaukee my condolences to his family
and friends
i hope they get answers and justice soon
well you probably won't be surprised to
know that the major networks outside of
fox didn't even mention this horrific
murder
not a peep from cnn msnbc
the washington post the new york times
abc news
cbs news or nbc
and this led youtubers to pick up the
slack
and ask some pretty basic questions
i can't for the life of me fathom
how it's justified that just because
somebody
is a trump supporter that they get
shot down in cold blood when they've
never ever
done anything to anybody other than
express their opinions
i even wonder if the mainstream
media is going to give it the amount of
coverage that it's given
some criminals out there that have died
in the streets
because they certainly don't give it to
children they don't get
the coverage no they don't
and no one knows their names as i said
but those victims
are people too like mr trammell was
that guy was just full of love it was
very deep conversations
he's just a community figure tonight the
ingram angle has exclusive video of
trammell's interactions just
days before his murder that may shed
light
on what was motivating the homicide
has did nothing for everybody say health
care we can't afford health care
we ain't got no money so trump
at least had whether the will of god
or his own inspiration to
do something that no president has ever
done
and that's why he got my vote if i stood
here with a sign saying
trump trump soldiers i get my i get a
rock thrown at me at best
one thing no fear come what made
she just called you disgusting well it
ain't right but
at the same time with america freedom of
expression
you know he seemed to truly believe that
didn't he well
we'll air more of that video later in
the show but at the very least it
reveals that mr tremble was aware that
he could be harmed for his pro-trump
views
now if this is true it's absolutely
appalling as is the deafening silence
from democrats
where's al sharpton where's black lives
matter a group that mr trammell
even supported by the way but they're
nowhere to be found
apparently certain black lives do not
matter
let's not forget the left's long history
of ignoring
vilifying or dehumanizing blacks who
disagree
they're called uncle toms or race
traders
they're not authentic just like biden
said you're not really black if you're
not a democrat
at least twice in the last few days
msnbc hosts
have proved my point has donald trump
ever
promised you anything financially in
exchange for your blind support
um of this administration or helping his
campaign no
and i've known him since 2015. are you a
paid campaign surrogate
are you being compensated
you only ask me that because i don't fit
your narrative
i like to turn the question on the
anchor and say are you a campaign
surrogate paid by the biden campaign
but how insulting is this how demeaning
you didn't think this way on your own
you couldn't have come to this
conclusion on your own
using your own intellect think about
that
the democrats and their radical media
collaborators have been pulling
a con on african americans for decades
the party of slavery and jim crow the
party of segregation
and the kkk has worked overtime to cover
up its own sins
in order to once again divide us along
racial and ethnic lines
now doing so requires that they demonize
disenfranchise
de-platform and dehumanize americans who
disagree
but they know i think that we're onto
them in their sick game
that more minorities are seeing through
their sloganeering about black lives
matter when in fact
they act like only certain black lives
matter
more decent people i believe are seeing
the pathetic
failure in leadership in democrat-run
cities
where black and immigrant-owned
businesses are destroyed with impunity
elected officials so possessed by
anti-trump hatred
that they actually do more to protect
the rights of violent protesters
than they do the rights of their own
law-abiding residents
now on occasion a few honest democrats
will speak out
as happened in a call with mayor lori
lightfoot early last month
we have to come up with a better plan
because once
my fear is once they're done looting and
rioting and
whatever's going to happen tonight what
are we going to do and what do we tell
our residents
other than good faith people stand up
it's not going to be enough
thank you alderman
next question well no i want an answer
i you commented on every but i want an
answer
i think you're 100 i think you're 100
did you get that to a democrat
city alderman you're 100 full of you
know what
it doesn't have to be this way
african-americans latinos
other immigrants who just want what
everyone else wants they want a fair
shot
they want decent schools they want safe
streets
they can walk away from the party that's
taken them for granted
and abuse their trust and support for an
agenda
that actually will respect their freedom
to make their own choices
and to believe whatever they want safe
streets bernell trammell wasn't killed
by a corrupt police officer
he was cut down in the middle of the day
after holding
a trump 2020 sign that was his
crime and that's the angle